players that come that represent you i
don't know if you're a sneaker guy
you're in the rocks uh ufc issued one so
hopefully these are cooler uh these are
the jordan 4
uh the lightnings for you wow you know
what a little throwback to brazil the
yellow i when i think you know i think
brazil dude so these are for you my man
these are from my boys at suplex and
philly which i will see in may so shout
out to the shots
our boys sent these man but wow these
are for you thanks for doing the show
brother we wish you nothing but the best
hopefully these make your kids jealous
now caveat with these don't wear these
in the favela right
i don't want to be responsible for you
getting jacked i think you're all right
okay i can't yeah okay yeah josiah not
on the first day no first date second
day second one
these are for you brother look at jason
jason look at his shoes yeah he's a
sneaker guy good man wow thank you so
much i appreciate it appreciate you man
give it burns everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you ready